it looked like the news she and her
family were waiting for
iran claiming a breakthrough in talks
with britain had secured nazanin zagari
ratcliff's release
the iranians said the uk had agreed to
settle a long-standing debt for tanks
paid for in the 70s
but never delivered by britain and in
return nazanin would be coming home
but the uk poured cold water on the
claims in a statement the foreign office
saying
we continue to explore options to
resolve this 40 year old case
and will not comment further as legal
discussions are ongoing
british sources told sky news nothing
has changed
earlier in the day foreign secretary
dominic raab leveled more criticism
at nazanin's iranian captors nazalene is
held
uh unlawfully in my view as a matter of
international law i think she's been
treated in the most abusive torturous
way uh i think it amounts to torture the
way she's been
uh treated and there is a very clear
unequivocal
obligation on the iranians to release
her and all of those who are being held
as leverage
immediately and without condition and
and we call on iran
to step up and comply with its
obligations
this is yet another false dawn for
nazanin and her family
but her husband richard wasn't sounding
disheartened
it's probably a good sign he said that
it's being signaled
just as last week's sentence was a bad
sign but it feels part of the
negotiations
rather than the end of them
in 1979 under the shah of iran iranians
paid 400 million pounds for british
chieftain tanks
britain failed to deliver when this
happened iran's islamic revolution
officially the british government says
the tank debt has nothing to do with
nazanin's fate
but iran's made it clear if it's paid
she has a better chance of being
released
her mp says it's time the debt was
settled
nazaneen was told herself by someone who
was interrogating her
when she was in prison in tehran that
her imprisonment was directly
linked to the uk's failure to pay this
debt
do i think we should pay it of course i
think we should pay it
whether or not it releases naznen if we
owe a country money
we should be paying it it is the latest
cruel twist to nazanin's unthinkable
ordeal
she should have been on a plane heading
home on march the 8th when her five-year
sentence ended
convicted instead on fresh charges if
diplomacy fails
she faces another two years at the least
before any chance of being reunited
with her family dominic waghorn sky news